The general experience,
and that's really what I'm doing at a
level that you can start in bed,
right?
So there's no more fucking excuses,
fucking excuses,
and that's so important because people
can feel sorry for themselves.
They can say they can't do it.
They don't have the energy there to beat
up.
That's bullshit.
There's always something you can do as
always if you.
But if you give yourself that fucking
excuse,
that's the problem.
What?
What I love about that video is if
anybody had an excuse,
it's that guy,
that guy,
I mean two canes,
giant belly blown out,
knees blown out,
back veteran paratrooper,
guide guide me,
jumping out of fucking airplanes over
and over again.
Blows his body apart and you fixed it
and he fixed it.
Fixed.
I just literally like credit.
So would I send them the food plant
right from,
from,
from Fred [inaudible],
his dream,
the food plan because it just regular
food.
But like what do you have the meeting
like chicken,
steak,
let's,
let's finish her.
So people's,
you'll hear me say in my program over
and over and over and over and over
again.
Make the DDP why your own bike.
And I explained to Arthur when I called
him.
Well here's what happened.
So he,
um,
he,
I sent him the food plan.
Let me say it.
And if he writes me back I think I can
do it.
I'll give it a try.
You go crazy.
No,
I go,
hey,
awesome.
Keep me posted.
But he said four words or he wrote for
words.
I can do this.
I said,
give me your number right now.
And I call the motherfucker up.
If you say you can use,
say you can't,
you're right.
You know that say you can't or you say
you can't.
You're right.
You said that originally who Henry Ford
was,
right?
Yeah.
And I always say,
what the fuck did he ever do?
What the fuck did he ever do?
But for when he said I can do it,
I said,
give me your number.
So I called them and I said,
Yo,
we talked for about an hour.
Two weeks later he calls me back.
The main thing I talked to him in in in
that conversation,
which is again what positively on stop
was all about as important as the
workout is,
as important as the eating plan is 10
percent of the equation.
The 90 percent is right between your
ears right here,
that six inch piece of real estate,
the story you tell yourself,
and I said,
if you can really just get past that
story and start
telling yourself a different story,
and example would be when I had,
when I went from my hall of fame
Induction Speech in front of 20,000
people in millions of people on USA and
on the wwe network,
which is only nine 99.
By the way,
it's like a rib bottom line is,
is that I wasn't in the back going,
Oh God,
I hope I don't fuck this up.
what if I forget what was going to say,
Oh God,
this sucks.
What if I.
What if I fuck up?
I wouldn't say.
Now I'm saying this can be the best
thing ever done.
I'm going to blow people away and make
them laugh.
Make them cry.
I'm going to inspire them and that was
my inner voice.
I went out there,
did the best thing I've ever done.
It's the best thing I've ever done,
but it's about that story that you tell
yourself when you get all this shit and
that's why people listen to you because
they want.
They need to be reminded it over and
over and over again.
You know,
the way you think about things is so
important.
It's so important.
It's almost more important than the
facts,
right?
The Way and the way this guy decided
that he was going to change his life,
that that video is so important to
people.
I mean,
if there's ever.
That's the best testimonial video you're
ever going to say.
I'm running boldly with an l by my name,
right?
So I'm trying to change the brand so
it's a decent brand is what I'm doing.
Or you put libertarian,
all my stuff.
I'm almost libertarian so I'm trying to
build the brand out to be a better
brand.
So if I win the brands better,
people will do that,
will raise my money,
there'll be a real third party.
I mean,
there'll be a third party in the United
States which will make better Democrats
and Republicans will literally be a
better nation,
a better a politic will be better in
America if I actually win this damn
thing,
but let's say I lose Sam wrong.
My things,
my mind isn't wrong.
Whatever people don't agree,
I lose.
Doesn't matter.
The bold ideas are still out there.
What you heard,
what your audience hurt is still there.
Someone's going to pick this up,
some of us,
or talk about it,
and if you're fine with that 100
percent,
what?
Yes,
please.
I want to fix things I'm not concerned
with who gets the credit for it.
Let's fix it.
I'm going to a better place to live this
cutters in trouble.
Nielsen.
Here's the perfect example of,
of,
of where we're going.
I don't want that to be the rest of this
nation.
We can fix,
steal all my stuff.
Please steal it all.
Awesome.
I hope you steal it.
I hope California copies me and does
everything I said it'd be amazing.
Please do that.
It'd be awesome,
but if people don't hear me,
if I don't get out there,
if I don't have to debate stage and I
don't come in second or third,
then no one's going to hear me because
I'm going to be forgotten,
but if I come in second or tight third,
there'll be a microphone in my face for
the next two years and every time it's
out there I'll be saying stuff just like
this again and again and again and maybe
manage a system isn't perfect,
but guess what?
Someone will figure out the right one.
It won't be.
Just keep giving it money.
It won't be that.
It'll be something that'll actually
work.
It'd be something brand new and exciting
and get people to come back to our
state.
What I don't want is what's happening
now is kids get educated,
they leave.
They don't come back with the educators
someplace else and never come back.
It's the wrong answer.
I'm really into craftsmanship,
man.
I always have been.
I love handmade pool cues and this desk,
which is handmade desk and I feel like
it's one of the things that I really
appreciate in this modern digital world.
And I also feel like unfortunately it
may be one of the things that slipping
away.
It definitely is slipping away.
I think with um,
you know,
with technology,
technology has been great for us and a
lot of different ways.
Like we couldn't be fucking talking into
a piece of metal and it's recorded on
the computer going through a wire flying
to the air.
Like it does a lot of great things.
But in doing all those great things,
it actually has taken us away from
really creating and working with our
hands.
And so like,
you know,
even this whole like a farm to table
movement where people even growing their
own vegetables,
you got your own chickens,
they're,
they're laying eggs for you.
Like knowing where this stuff is coming
from.
Having firsthand contact with that.
I'm just having that relationship in
general with.
It brings so much more value to the
overall experience of eating those eggs
are using that knife or sitting at this
fucking table right here
and it seems like a fairly recent
movement in that direction.
Right?
Like it feels like things got so digital
that people like,
whoa,
Whoa,
whoa.
What the facebook and the fucking
instagram I want to.
I want a wood table.
I want to solve this myself.
Yeah.
Your hands on it.
I don't want it to be plastic.
Yeah.
I want real stuff.
And there's something about handmade
things,
whether it's a handmade pair of boots or
handmade bag.
Like it's like there's something about
things that are made by hand that people
get like a deep appreciation of.
For sure.
Well,
and I think it,
I think it also kind of goes back,
like I was saying,
like as technology has advanced,
we've kind of grown away from these
kinds of what's considered like blue
collar work and craftsmanship kind of
work,
but I think people really are driven by
a sense of achievement and when you're
doing data entry that literally millions
of people fucking monkeys can be trained
to do.
Not to like diminish anything that
anybody's doing but literally like
to be able to go into a craft and to and
had a hands on experience is very,
very,
very different in that sense of
achievement.
Even when somebody comes out of
something and maybe I taught a class on
how to make a knife and it looks like a
fucking Turd,
they're going to think it looks like the
most beautiful fucking knife they've
ever seen in their life because their
hands and their creative,
they touch their energy,
their,
their sweat and pop.
Probably some of their blood is put into
creating that thing and that brings that
much more value to it.
Like,
like I was,
like I was saying earlier,
you can get kids to believe in anything
he could bring.
I could,
I could get my son into Satan
essentially.
He'd be all in all about Lucifer.
Boom.
I got them into the brown kids.
Little Kids,
you know?
Yeah,
totally.
He's,
he's so into the dodgers because his
grandpa is under the daughter,
so he's all about the dodgers and I got
him into the browns is all in the browns
now too because I could get them into
anything.
So I sat him down and I say,
you are going to sit you down and I'm
going to show you the master of the
nunchucks and it's Bruce Lee.
He's number one.
He's,
he's the greatest martial artist of all
time.
I broke them and I sat him down and put
them in front of the TV to that.
Should have filmed this.
Did you fill the whole thing?
You filmed,
you saying it to him?
No,
I didn't film that,
but I filmed it.
I filmed him watching Bruce Lee.
I'm a first.
I showed him the greatest nunchucks
scenes of all time with Bruce Lee that
you can go to youtube and you can see
there's,
there's compilations.
They put together the one from the stuff
in,
enter the dragon,
this stuff in a Chinese connection,
a way of the dragon or or return of the
dragon and a.
So I sat them down and go,
I'm going to blitz them with this shit.
I'm going to make sure that whenever he
thinks about fucking nunchucks he knows
that Bruce Lee's the master.
Right?
So he's just completely blown away.
Then after I showed them other nunchucks
scenes with,
I sat them down and I want them to show
them the greatest fights of all time.
Bruce Lee versus Chuck fucking Norris.
Come on man.
So I just want her to leave that just in
his DNA and I fill in that.
I filmed him watching a chuck Norris and
Bruce Lee.
Any old always wants to know he.
He loves.
He loves Bruce Lee instantly,
and he,
he,
he needs to know who wins the fight.
So like daddy does.
Bruce Lee.
When I go always when sunny always wins
and,
but my natural reaction,
because he's constantly asking
questions,
he's constantly does he,
when my natural reaction would be just
watch,
watch you gotta,
watch this because it's going to be
sweeter if you watch it and you go
through the ups and downs and he goes,
no data.
You need to tell me now.
And I go,
no,
you're gonna like it more if you just
watch it.
You got no daddy does.
Bruce Lee when he wants to fucking know
he don't want to be disappointed.
Yeah.
So he got two years old.
He got completely blown away.
So a week later,
a week later I got today you're going to
watch the greatest martial arts movie of
all time.
Enter the Dragon.
Bruce Lee.
Dad,
isn't it?
I go,
yes.
It's the real main chimpanzee.
Yeah.
That was gonna be like,
so if there's anything.
I was like,
holy cow.
What movie was that?
It looked really cool.
Chimpanzee,
who is it?
A documentary?
Yeah.
It's kind of like a documentary.
I was like,
damn,
I'm sure.
I mean,
they're mean.
They're cruel.
They,
they're,
they're calculated.
Yeah.
They sneak up on each other and like,
I didn't realize chimps did calculator.
Cruelty.
Yeah.
How's pretty
left that meeting?
Kind of like game over.
This is dark,
right?
Well,
we know better because we've advanced,
but if we hadn't,
we'd be like,
man,
I don't want to fucking live in a house.
I like the champ ways,
bro.
Chimp ways to go.
This is it man.
Chimp life right now,
but we in a way to the AI might be like,
those chimps were like these stupid Fox
launching missiles out of drones and
shooting each other underwater.
Like we're crazy.
We got torpedoes,
submarines and fucking airplanes that
drop nuclear bombs.
Indiscriminantly on cities were assholes
too.
Yeah.
They might go,
why are they doing this?
It might look at our politics.
Look at what we do in terms of our,
our,
our food system.
What,
what kind of food?
We forced down each other's and they
might
go this,
these people crazy.
Didn't even look out for themselves.
I don't know.
How much do we think about chimps?
Not much.
Very little.
It's like these chimps are at war that
these like little
groups of chimps just attack each other
and they kill each other.
They torture each other.
That's pretty bad.
The monkees a there,
but like this is probably the most.
But you know,
I mean when's the last time you talked
about trips with me?
All the time.
If you do talk to the podcast,
dude that's talking about chimps
episode,
people are laughing right now.